it's mine
both all kinds of negative times the
negative
um i've been negative son i know you
have been why this is
i i feel good i want to say for the
record i want to say for the record
still against the shutdown
as a guy who had it yep that keeping my
kids out of school
makes zero sense even though every
single
developed nation has their children in
school because it doesn't affect kids
and yet we're keeping my children who go
to public school
out of school i'm against that and
again i say there's a smarter way to do
this um so i'm doubling down on that
and i wish us talking about it it would
change anything it won't change
so you know what i'm sick of hearing
about here's the problem a lot a lot of
problems
one is you can't do anything about this
one is so just you're learning about the
tides of change
number two i don't like getting my
coffee and having
the woman i get my coffee from say you
lost a lot of weight
hey yeah is it from homegirl like you
you have a fat compliment like i have a
skinny
is it from home what would you like to
haze little no no not a little haze
why do we call it haze uh i don't
remember
is she cute but for me
you have like if i look to you and i go
oh you're getting some big little
heavy you go oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] you're
looking skinny i go i immediately go
come on damn it ruins my whole day when
you got your coffee we have been
sick of [ __ ] yeah i even tell you about
my friend
who uh who pull he's a he's a larger
black man okay and he says when he takes
a piss sometimes
and he looks down on his dick he's got a
regular dick ah it's a bubble he
he he it ruined his whole day he told us
that when like he goes
i'll look at my dick sometimes and i
just go [ __ ]
then he told me an amazing story about
how
he stepped off a curb and a car
hit like a van was so close that it
actually
burned hit the end of his nose oh damn i
don't believe it
yeah go okay assume no true story and he
went
[ __ ] so was the side man i don't know
think about it brian so was the sidebar
he probably stepped off after it went
oh so there's the back end so so he's
he's i don't call it and then i don't
know but either way but just talk
logistics you almost got it because it's
not fast and furious seven
so the mirror sticks out right like the
mirror sticks
so the mirror would have went like this
and then you were like whoa
crazy in the car all right so maybe it
never happened but carry on
that never happened you almost got
killed by a fan my grandpa killed his
knots now i know that story
you know and i don't like you you know
when i was driving i went ah that never
happened did it i just i'm 37 realized
ramp a lot this almost happened to me in
seattle i was on my phone stepped off
and almost got killed by
but did you did it did it skin your nose
well i mean in other words it was that
close he said he could feel the air on
his nose
so it skins your nose though not mine
his
oh okay and then remember that time when
i watched
it
remember i almost got hit by a car you
got i do remember that oh
wasn't close i still go like this wasn't
that close i don't know it was kind of
close
it was from me to cat no that's not true
yeah it was that's absolutely and i
walked like this no no you are very
[ __ ] close
okay can answer your friends i saved
your life you did
now he i don't know why i'm telling you
the story but he
he went oof holy [ __ ] right holy [ __ ]
goes to take a piss all set to be upset
about his dick
and faints and died he fainted because
please tell me he died it was like a
reflective delay of realizing he almost
died
no he didn't die i'm just but then
and it was mr t in there and it was mr t
i knew it
so so you guys figure that out
so my takeaway from this the blackout i
like i like your detective work
because i not the movies i was told that
story i know
but now that you say the mirror you got
to keep the mirror in mind yeah think of
the side mirrors that'd be the first
time i'm going to probably kill you
going fast enough right rip off if it
gives it's gonna [ __ ] you up if it gives
[ __ ] you up but that was all they always
fold in right so it's bringing a
fold in yeah well on instagram there was
a [ __ ] guy on a motorcycle i don't
thought that did you see that on the car
gets hit by a van
and and then they kind of skid off like
this
and the motorcycle goes zoom like just
me oh my god it was like
talk about a [ __ ] ninth life i mean
it was so crazy
motorcycles are dangerous
i don't care how good you are oh they
look so tasty though when i
when you're in traffic you know what i
was on my bike today going downhill i'm
cruising
wind's in my face i got my tunes in you
know i'm like oh this is great
a motorcycle how good this is i bet
that's
yeah 100 times it also focuses your mind
it's so much
more dangerous but it makes sense why
they do it well the people i know who
ride and bike say
it focuses your mind your mind is so
focused to be
there's a flow that you get into here's
the other thing they say it's not if
it's when you crash
oh it's not bad big problem for me small
crash big crash
i got a problem with that oh dude i know
you're all bunched up in inside your
home right now because that shit's going
on
yeah i have a dock for your old ass
think making the murderer marry you we
love making you like
part two sucked think of an original
making a murderer then
anna hernandez documentary then you love
them right yeah now imagine those two
had a baby
and then out came this documentary
called outcry
five part series outcry dude new
new next stop showtime showtime sound
like a homer
it's okay showtime five part series
right my brian daley my boy at showtime
texas
hey not sure if you watch uh outcry it's
right up your alley and i was like oh
yeah would it you know all right what is
it
he tells me like all right last night
nothing to watch it's about nine o'clock
sucked in and i was like i need
something [ __ ] it i'll check it out
click on it
dude i don't what's it about dude don't
tell manny just tell me what it's about
let me tell you what it's about
kid named greg kelly right outside
austin texas stud football player
handsome dude sure super stud i got a
division one scholarship had three
offers from rice
uh texas san antonio decides to go to ut
sa university of texas san antonio gets
a full ride
he's the star football player stutter
the town their
big 5a school so he's a [ __ ] stud
right
his one position i think he was a safety
or but either way white guy right a
white and
latin mix his family his mom
for some reason they have to leave the
district and go move over here
and but he's in his senior year and he
goes well
i i got finished you know i had my
senior year coming up i had to play
so a booster who's a big lady booster
lady for the football team goes
he can stay with me he can stay with me
the mom goes oh my god that's so nice of
you
yeah no problem family moves he stays
there for a senior year
she oh it's so good dude she runs a
daycare there
right it's the summer and next thing you
know the kid gets a call
from uh the texas police i think austin
police and goes
uh you've been accused of sexual assault
against a four-year-old boy
he's been staying there he goes excuse
me jesus christ
a four-year-old boy they show the video
this four-year-old being interrogated by
the detectives
and as a as a father you watch this i i
have a four-year-old right now
there's no way the kid would make this
up the kid goes yeah
greg asked me to uh if he could put his
pee pee in my mouth
and you're watching and you're pissed
and i'm sick to myself i'm like oh [ __ ]
this dude are you kidding me it's
unbelievable
so uh under texas law they call it
super aggravated sexual assault against
a minor
the least you can give the least it's
already a good law it's a great
it sounds great it sounds like a cool
car the least you could get
is 20 cars it's 25 years with no parole
that's the minimum well you got to get
them off the street you can have people
like that
right i agree with it the maximum is 99
years no parole okay so 25 to 99.
then he's like what so they book them
they take them in
a week later another kid comes out
another kid comes out
like what the [ __ ] so before they they
were going to go to
trial the prosecution goes hey
you can plea and you get five years
parole
no prison no fire's parole but you're
convicted sexual
uh predator you're a lifesaver and the
kid goes i i'm innocent no i'm not
taking that deal
i'm not taking a deal let's go to court
i'm innocent they go to court
they find him guilty of both accounts
they found guilty and you're like what
the [ __ ] now don't tell me anymore
dude you told me a little too much dude
now hold on wait teeth
i mean so dude i'm telling you dude
it's a five part series and i started on
episode one i was like oh
my i look up my girl we don't say a word
for the
i think they're each of 60 minutes long
we don't say a single word riveting
oh dude it's unbelievable
what happens to this kid well you
watched the whole thing
no bubble i was up to 2 a.m you can't
stop
my detective shop was on the cake yeah
you got it you figured it out i figured
out by episode 3 what's going on really
interesting kid's name's greg kelly okay
it's
but i've been as a father yeah i mean
the kids because one could get
well the kids did get actually molested
yeah all right
no more no more no more no spoilers i'm
now i'm in
oh yeah how could you watch that tonight
i'll tell you
tonight i gotta tell you i
i don't know what was worse the covet in
my lungs or the
[ __ ] boredom of having to be at home
watching my steps walking back and forth
you're out of it now papa i know
and you put whatever you couldn't and
you you posted your test
posted my negative test cat got her test
chin needs to take it this week
yeah jun said covet for 47 days yes yes
he'll be all right he's getting better
and better it it's not to be rushed
madame corona madame corona
mistress kovid she takes her respect
especially 53 years she takes her time
and she won't be rushed if you're older
for sure oh if you're older don't
don't rush your hand don't you're ready
for this might make people
mad she'll tell you when recess she will
she will i've had when i've had
allergy attacks worse out i've rolled in
dandelions and a lot of people are that
way yeah now isn't that weird
isn't it weird how it affects different
people yeah crazy well you know me i
just went through
an hour and a half of breaking down my
entire genome i went to health nucleus
where they look at everything full body
scan
heart uh cat scan i'm good
but the best news is i i've avoided i'm
not
predisposed to any kind of god forbid
but any kind of uh
cancer diet tomorrow you know like yeah
exactly from from genetics i don't have
any weird genetics my genetics
in your family no cancer nothing dude
i'm very lucky that's thick
everybody everybody in my family lives
forever and they don't get weird
diseases
that's just luck that's just [ __ ]
luck of the draw now
might die who [ __ ] knows i don't i
don't understand you know papa kellan's
cholesterol he dick
well papa collects papa's counselor no
papa county
i know i was i was high yo michael
i'll tell you what yours is high your
pop is high say what else is high and
you know this
my testosterone my natural i don't take
any trt
or any of that [ __ ] and i have it i have
my testosterone my natural testosterone
is 11. so 11 you could just say 1100.
for for a 53 year old apparently that's
off the charts
most guys my age i was they would get
the guys who followed us said 300 you're
probably 300 400
yeah i'm eleven hundred i'm over so you
have so much energy
now balding i know usually guys with
high testosterone that's why they go
bald that's probably true
yeah my dick is always you're always
it's always
ready to go you're ready to go never had
a problem with it so now you don't
now you never have to get on trt well
not for now but i was that that was
something i was always thinking about
but i
didn't want to remember i told you i
didn't want to [ __ ] with my energy
system because i always felt i told you
i wouldn't wrong and athletic yeah i
wouldn't
you know i just felt you know and then
you take that and then you're freaking
i know what do you do then you gotta no
no i don't want to [ __ ] with that
if it goes low and i'm feeling like i
don't have energy but my mother
who i take after my mother at 80 like my
mother will tell you because i have
energy all day
i feel fantastic you've never had an
issue my mother walked when she was 65
she walked
just to see if she could do it she
walked 26 miles in a clip
she just walked just walked straight
yeah so you know that's what's up
it's walking she always has she's she
still has energy
yeah at 86. my grandma my uncle lived
till he's 96.
that dude oh i have you know what else i
have i have the foxo gene
do you know what that is that's the
longevity gene oh really
that's that's where i will live i have a
very high chance of living
to 90 or or over they read your palm too
they know this is all genome stuff this
is all genome stuff
it's all science health nucleus it's
craig venter's viking too what else do
you tell you well no i've got i've got
i'm southern italian and i'm
i'm i'm nor uh northwestern european
but no i've got the foxhole gene boxo
that's called the fox
boxo look it up the foxo gene is a gene
that some people have it's a longevity
gene so the majority of people that live
like if they're centerian the
fox og and the foxtrot gene yeah that's
cool man just tell me what i got
i know that's cool i test i know foxy
all good news i don't like
no i don't like you don't why are you
pissing on my parade right now i'm not
this long i'll show you my whole [ __ ]
no i know and i'm sure they sent you all
these yeah they did
yeah they did i know the foxo gene is
real the fox oh gene's real yeah
don't read your text sir would you first
stay back in studio man come on
i'm just looking at my no you're looking
at a tax
oh so uh yeah so you got eleven hundred
dollars
i don't like how much cost money i i
don't like talking about this stuff
because none of it means anything
because you can die tomorrow for
whatever reason
at least she got fox though yeah and
they told you to live to
200 basically i said nothing's wrong
with me yeah
so i'm going to live until i'm 200. it's
good to know though
you have high it's a good baseline to
know what kind of
guess what i can't take guess what's not
good for me hydrochloroquinine
the the the the stuff you took yeah so
for me
specifically if i take that the drug you
took when you had covid
that's not good for some people i happen
to be one of them now
i have i get psoriasis so that can be a
hint of it
but apparently that particular drug and
a couple of other drugs
like for diabetes and hypertension i
shouldn't take them because i have a
certain gene variation
and and quinine or whatever the [ __ ]
that is i don't know what it is that can
cause
apparently my hemoglobin to shoot off a
bunch of iron
in my liver dumps do some [ __ ] weird
thing but you wouldn't know that unless
you did your genome
so i'm one of the few people that you
know and then they told you
hydroxychloroquine yeah
sure and then you can't eat uh
nightshades can't eat nightshades
feel 100 it's good that you did this
very good
yeah can't have nightshades i'll be
honest with you and then uh it's well
worth you have the gene where you can
uh no sleep no i need my sleep
sleep is everything did they tell you uh
they tell you you can't eat red meat
you know what red meat is not good for
me there you go
red meat for me because i have high iron
good for probably
to i guess you can't break it down
correctly ferrous my ferrous levels get
high in the liver
and also my cholesterol stay away from
red meat
i don't like your attitude dude
it's not no when you walked out did they
do they give you the beads to put around
hey
or do they nail those this is a
scientific thing
this is science dude no you broke down
my chino yeah sure
are you meaning every sunday in the park
no but i'm gonna have to go back
to check on assist on my pancreas of
course you do you have a sisty
little sister a little assistant little
small cyst in my pancreas yeah i have
one on my
sure it's nothing i have one on my brain
yeah i don't like they'll say you got to
watch it just in case again how do i
watch it
i'm like well pre-cancerous on your
pancreas is not a good thing well how
the [ __ ] do i watch it though how do you
keep an eye on your [ __ ] no
how do i keep an eye on that that's when
they told me that that that benign tumor
on my brain
you just gotta keep an eye on it i mean
if it gets any bigger well
you mean you mean i'll know if i go
blind in one eye then i come back in
you're not a big hypochondriac because
you had some [ __ ] going on well you
can't see out of one eye all of a sudden
you start throwing up some bad times
yeah you don't you don't need to worry
about it
no i should probably go down there to
your
cult i will say this when you're feeling
low energy and shitty like kova did to
me
your fear of death kind of goes away
it's not as strong because you're like
i don't feel good like people get really
sick like alex trebek who has
pancreatic cancer and he was like i'm
done he's like he's like if this one
doesn't pick up i'm done yeah i just
don't i know people have gone through
that well that was that was my uncle pax
you know he beat
county with cancer esophageal in his
mouth
and then he did chemo it took away all
his teeth all his taste buds so he
couldn't taste
no and then it comes back is i'm not
doing it again i'm out
yeah i'm out my quality of life is awful
yeah he's like i'd rather just go that's
what he did who wants that [ __ ] that's
why alex trebek said right
yeah well you you see you can understand
that
i get i guess awful
yeah it's like i don't want to keep live
another 10 to 12 years with oh this is
chemo has to kill everything so so it
kills all the new cells that's why you
lose your hair
and and stuff because you you are it's a
retrovirus cancer
so you you have to kill the actual virus
and the cells that it's
you know that's kind of how it works i
think jesus christ yeah
it's it's we will find targeted
therapies and we are
but yeah they said that in like you know
100 years we'll look back on
chemotherapy and they're going to laugh
good news on a covet vaccine right today
yeah oxford came out said the you know
should have one by the end of the year i
can't wait
i can't wait i don't know yeah that
would be nice to get back to
regular life i just feel like i nothing
worse than
putting me in a position where i feel
like i have no power i mean what are you
gonna do buddy complain
worry or adapt well you wouldn't want to
complain at least you're fortunate
enough where you can work
i agree thank you for the podcast bubba
not worried about me i'm worried about
people i'm worried about the [ __ ]
world i'm worried about the economy
that that is what i think about but well
you should have been a politician
if you want to make some real change so
i can have so i can realize i can't make
a change
so i can be a politician and realize i'm
pl i have to play the game
it's all tough dude now even the nfl's
having some hiccups because
you know god bless the nfl you know the
america runs off the blood of the nfl
and now the players like hold up dude
you want us because i think
rookies report this thursday rookies and
quarterbacks were i think this week
and then they're just going to power
through like again if i was like we're
going let's go
the player's like no we're not we you
don't give us any protocol on the safety
or
anything we're just not showing up to
camp with no protocol testing or nothing
but
you and i are on the same page and this
young people who are athletes and stuff
need to get
need to look at the actual stats none of
them look at their chances none of them
have ever died right
i know and when you're under 34 you're
not going to die from this
you're more likely to be hit by
lightning yeah so you have to look at
the stats
and yeah it's like it's like at schools
okay so so my friend's a doctor at
school and he spoke on the board
and these parents are not doing their
research and they're saying i don't want
my kid to get sick
hey [ __ ] you gotta look at the
stats
you have to look at the your child has a
much better chance of dying
of the flu yeah and and how do you for
the kids
how do you get into ignorant like people
are ignorant well they're not doing the
research
well i i don't know to play devils out
they're just afraid well to play devil's
advocate you could say that
kids aren't affected by corona because
they're not in school and they're not
around each other if anyone's been
locked down
in europe europe is different bubba so
to sweden so
the the countries these developed
countries that have their children in
full swing
in in korea japan they beg to differ
so we know that kids are not affected by
listening and actually have a very hard
time
passing it on well dude when i had it
the least thing i was worried about was
time of course
he's fine even talking to my dad he's
like even if they got it they might
be a small fluffy doesn't a small
chicken yeah and people talk about this
yashimoto's disease whatever the [ __ ] it
is or yamasaki's disease
where some kids get hypertension and
stuff all right very rare once again
your child has a better chance of dying
of the flu god forbid than covent
and and you can't get through to some
people they're just a lot of moms are
just hysterical and too afraid it comes
to kids it's tough yeah
but you got to look at the stats because
you might be doing more harm than good
anyway yeah i don't know moving on yeah
um he's still biking oh yeah every day
every day papa release numero do you
want to take me through these uh these
shoes of yours uh these jordan threes
he's new the toros ah not that new
not that new uh do you want to take me
through your
baggy blue socks that don't match with
anything these are my boosts
and uh what i'll do is i'll recycle
socks so i wear them one day
and i go warm for a couple hours i'm
gonna wear them again i do the same yeah
i do that i do that with all my stuff i
don't like to waste water
i do the same uh yeah my buddy one time
it bothers me i think about it once a
week and i don't know why this is
15 years ago he's a little bit of a
spoiled nancy
he's been he was coddled as a kid he put
on some [ __ ] jeans
okay he went downstairs his wife said it
might be hot for those jeans and he said
you're probably right took him off put
him in the [ __ ]
laundry hamper well that's laziness and
i went
well that's just lazy those aren't dirty
and he goes man i know but
that's lazy that's lazy i've done that
bothered me i've done that before all
right you guys
i'll just throw them on the ground get
them out right now fold them well i'll
just throw mine on the ground [ __ ]
fold them and throw them in the ground
because i'll wear them again yeah don't
put them in a laundry hamper it bothers
me
i get it though it's lazy maybe you just
want to put on there because i didn't
feel like rehanging it you know
bought two blazers this weekend bought
two blazers oh yeah
are you going to wear this let me ask
you this i wear them why buy blazers you
have nowhere to go
because and b where the [ __ ] are you
going that
people are feeding you because i'm a
high testosterone 53 year old
and a man of my age should wear a blazer
and a convertible
corvette nope convertible corvette
yellow right in case i get into a
situation why did you buy blazers where
are you gonna wear those pop off
wherever i want when it's chilly and
when it's not chilling
i'm gonna be a blazer guy where'd you go
to buy them
uh i i went to rag and bone
good good i'll fabric and they had a
sale they opened they couldn't resist
they were open yeah and they had a sale
well i mean [ __ ] yeah no [ __ ] you know
what i mean everywhere's on sale yeah so
i got some good threads
for very cheap so you wear it at your
house
i couldn't i couldn't resist well once
they come up with a vaccine i'll be out
on the town
yeah you look fresh papa i wanna look
fresh need some shoes not gonna lie the
vaccine
is gonna take a little bit to get to us
huh
probably buddy i'll be raising a glass
and then we'll get another [ __ ] virus
no don't be negative nancy
i don't know when uh thing's gonna open
back up as far as
cat do you know anybody who has coven um
besides you guys no
no i don't how you feeling i'm good
nothing's wrong
you look great nothing's wrong nothing
is wrong at all
we love cat um love you guys too
what did you think of the fights which
ones joey benavidez and a tough one
poor joey well one guy's on his way up
the other guy's
you know just a bummer figuerito
brazilian monster
just a such a bummer yeah it's good
fights this weekend
darren till whitaker whitaker that's
going to be
verdum
gustin is fighting heavyweight now yep
which i think is a very good move
me too also little nog shogun
little noggin show that's cool i don't
want to watch that
i don't it's the co-main event and
that's strong i know i don't
i don't want to see great legends take
damage i i just don't like it
i just don't i mean at least at least
it's at least they're not finding young
guys
this is not some young [ __ ] monster
thank god i would have restrictions on
that
i really would like if you're if you're
a little nogger or
nog well if you want to talk but you
know shogun or little nog they don't get
into it just to fight old heads they
want to fight for a title so because
then to get there you go
you have to protect them from themselves
as we know the ufc's number come on dude
they've never done that like a bj penn
gov system could be the heavyweight
champion he could because uh
dc and stipe the winner that they're
both who doesn't matter they're both
going to retire
are they both going to retire yeah i
think they're both done i hope they both
do yeah
so nothing to prove they're incredible i
mean i know dc's done for sure i don't
know stipe
that's a great fight justin curtis
blades guess when derek lewis there's so
much fun playing
his hands full good match would you say
he's the best striker in the um
in the heavyweight division no al
stronger
he's not slower he's not i mean he might
be but as far as technically like
fundamentals also brings the best
striker in heavyweight history k1
champion
rose and strokes no punk you look at his
background right
jds is no punk no jds is taking so much
damage though
you know dustin's not young dude he's
taking a lot how old is gus
i don't know but he's hurt he's retired
before too yeah yeah he always had a
precarious
well he's always been like right there
so he's been right there he's a huge
he's a superstar in sweden right
superstar
billboards everywhere about six six oh
he's ever been at 66
yeah dwarf i saw him with his [ __ ]
shoes off oh he dwelt backstage dude
for me jesus he's 33. he's 33.
mma 33. some wars with dc jon jones
a lot rumble johnson like he's had some
tough goes man
yes he is um whitaker
till great fight
i got whitaker oh why is that
i mean he's the underdog but slight
slight it's basically evil interesting
underdog it's interesting i'm sorry
till's the only tell the girl i'm sorry
first thing i thought you picked kill
no i got i got whitaker yeah he's the
slight favorite probably hits a little
harder
more explosive yeah i don't know if he
hits hard he's more explosive
till's a monster dude i can't believe
tell us fight 170.
well when he stepped into the ring
against huge uh uh donald cerrone
apparently he was 204 pounds oh yeah
monster it's nuts how he can lose that
weight whitaker took some time off he's
had some injuries you know he also went
through [ __ ] two wars with
romero and then he got knocked out by
stalin dude
yeah that's right that's heavy [ __ ]
that's like we always say like you have
a certain number of rounds in you
they remember tale though his last fight
was against kelvin gaslamin when i think
split decision was a war man yeah it was
awesome and before that he lost him
and woodley woodley did he get knocked
out or he got you got submitted
yeah that's right basically knocked down
and submitted yeah been a tough go
great fight though who else is fighting
on that card
that's about i mean for for this that's
about it i mean this is the bane
you know your money's on whitaker i'm
not i wouldn't put money on the fight
we're not bet on this fight too close to
a fight love both guys too much
wouldn't bet on it way too you don't who
knows what's gonna happen
well that's the show so thanks for
watching there we are we have nothing to
do
it was just that home huh nothing to do
i'm gonna work out for the first time
well didn't you kind of work out like i
mean i've been working out yet but
i've been walking a lot of doing a
little lifting what are you gonna do to
help myself
but i'm gonna do a formal workout you're
gonna go somewhere outside
doing an outside workout with somebody
like holding mitts
no oh you oh i wouldn't mind doing that
were you you're
like barbell and stuff like i want to
see what my wind is and
how i feel but you can do it like in
this like in the beach or something
i'm going to do it uh in a parking lot
in the sunshine oh
yeah push myself a little bit wear a hat
too
but why are they doing the parking lot
they don't want you in the gym it's an
outdoor gym
pop-up gin oh not like uh is it uh
deuces
no no this is one-on-one oh it's only
one-on-one i'm just gonna do that for a
little bit even though i tested negative
just to yeah just out of courtesy i
don't want any flack
i'm still being careful why would you
have flack i don't know i'm just being
careful
too worried dude i know but
it's fine all right let's bring in chin
okay come on chin
shipstation.com this is a company
that makes it easier faster more
affordable to manage and ship
your orders whatever they might be with
a few clicks you can be managing your
orders printing out labels getting your
product happy customers
ship station makes it that easy okay jay
shobs used it man yup
big j shop use it for finding kid merch
before ship station helps online sellers
of any size get orders out quickly save
money on shipping costs
keep your customers happy amazon etsy
your own website
it brings all the orders into one simple
interface do they work with usps though
dude
yes they do fedex usps fedex they use
ups
amazon fulfillment anything you want you
can compare and choose this the
best shipping solution for you and your
customers
and you get posted discounts they're
usually reserved for large fortune 500
companies
you'll always know that you're getting
the best deal no wonder ship station's
number one choice of online sellers just
ship more and less time with the best
rates available
and right now tfat k listeners can try
shipstation free
for 60 days when you use the code
fighter make sure your business is ready
to meet the demands of delivery culture
get started at shipstation.com today
click on the top of the page and type in
fighter that's shipstation.com then
enter code
fighter click on the microphone top of
the page oh i'm sorry that's
shipstation.com to enter the code
fighter shipstation.com make ship happen
draftkings if you want to put your
sports knowledge
where your money is draftsking
draftkings
does it for you jesus christ dude you
got to see the united knight
yep ufc i want i got it buddy from here
go ahead you take it easy
all right ufc fight night 174
this saturday whitaker versus still
shogun versus little nog
you got gus of inverse verdoom make
money you know who's gonna win
you know what round you think they're
going how they're gonna do it does it go
over the rounds to go under the rounds
there's a million ways to make money man
get going right now head to the app
right now check out all they have to
offer
including player props live betting so
much more you can bet on baseball too
english premier league spanish la liga
and more
yep but this saturday ufc fight night
till whittaker make bank bro download
the top rated draftking sportsbook app
now and use the code fighter when you
sign up for limited time
all new users can get a signup bonus up
to a thousand dollars that's right
draftkings sportsbook
has a signup bonus up to a thousand
dollars just enter the code fighter
when you sign up only at draftkings book
read the red dude all right fine must be
21
older new jersey indiana pennsylvania
only a bonus compromise of first deposit
bonus and first
bet match each up to 500 deposit bonus
requires
25 times play through restrictions
applies to draftkings.com
sportsbooks for detail gambling problems
call 1-800 gambler
or in indiana 1-809 with it
hey kev my man kev here stepped in human
[ __ ] oh
human poo in hollywood he has a vid he
has a video of it it looks like peanut
butter
it's fresh too you know too you know
when it's [ __ ] dude this is
its own smell it's it's very greasy i
remember this guy
fell off get back get back new york city
goes human [ __ ] is what it is yeah
human [ __ ] he was like taking the hose
not man there's no confusing
if i could have been in a different
state i would have been in a different
state
so what happened is there was a car in
the way and so it's either you go around
it or you take this corner
yeah corner the frown's ahead of me you
look back at me he's like watch out for
that human [ __ ]
as soon as you're saying it i stepped in
you stepped in here and [ __ ] now i would
throw my shoe away now hold on
well he's hosing off but nope now hold
on don't don't step out
what size shoe do you think my man kev
wears yeah he might be an 11.
uh 11 hilarious he's a 15. what show him
your [ __ ] foot
got some problems brother hey you
[ __ ] clown
holy [ __ ] he's got human clown shoes 15.
do you own a clown car that's incredible
you might be a closet clown that's
impressive how the [ __ ] do you have size
15 shoes dude you're you know five eight
no my man kev has a
thick piece you work you don't have a
size 15
and not have a [ __ ] pepsi can for a
[ __ ] i hope it's not small if it's small
i'm going to lose my [ __ ] oh it's not
dude his hands are normal he's got
normal sized hands it's just that
no one says anything about hands he's
got big understanding
dude 15. kev let the people know
kev you go to nike town you got to go to
the weird section in the back right with
the psychiatrist
15 and 6. you know what as a kid it's
only like big air maxes and like nba
players shoes
as a kid they look to you and go kid's
going to be six four six five look at
those feet
didn't happen nope this kid get a
basketball in his hand
make sure this kid gets a mask on his
advertised
giant feet at least you have good
balance can you water ski
i bet congrats you have the biggest foot
of anyone i know kev
oh that must've been tough
thirteen fifth grade
do you have a condition do you have a
long
dude it's called 13 and yeah super long
toes
gigantism of just your foot yeah you've
got you know
no we can't just skim off your feet have
their own pituitary system dude a size
13 and 50. now he's got 15. my dad has a
size 14.
i've never seen him like that he's six
four he's huge yeah
kevin okay kevin how tall are you five
ten yeah maybe you might be five ten kev
was it a problem in school kids would
make fun of you
wait stand up let me see your feet like
just standing they're shoving don't come
over i can't see
they're so big that's the biggest one
i've seen in my life are they wide too
oh they're wide they're flat
you have flat feet too oh man kill
disaster
all right we're sports hard for you
yeah i know but you're just so you have
the biggest feat
of anyone i know i don't know anyone
where's this that big of a shoe
but you'd have to go to the nba sir 100
yeah yeah
what a shaq size 21 of 18 actually
i'm close to it yeah i think he's size
21 no he's not
there's hey brian there's no such thing
as size 20. i think i think shaq is no
he's like
17 no he's size 20 you want a bat yeah
i think he size 21 dude size 21
i think so did your doctor tell you this
holy [ __ ] i'm right size 22.
yeah i told you
22 foot yao means at 18 kevin durant's
in 18.
lebron james 15. the greatest of all
time
size 13. holla me too who's that
michael sorry
steph curry 13 and a half wilt chamber
and 15. wow
you're the same size as wilt wilt the
stilt god damn
how crazy that kid has a size 15 shoe
because i i looked at she's add some
extra shoes like you did what's that
shoe
where he's like 15 i was like i don't
have anything pretty let me tell you
something i don't want him in here
anymore
why because he looks like an ewok i just
don't trust i don't trust it i think
he's that big he's going to take a real
friend he might be he might be a forest
warlock and i i don't know what's going
on he looks like an
uh an ewok with air force ones there's
something [ __ ] supernatural about
that guy and it's not
good i don't know literally he's
literally the knight
he's the nicest yeah he's so [ __ ]
nice my favorite
i don't trust usually he just getting
questions
here he is again do you um
you know kev guys you worship the prince
of darkness candid
this is a company i plan on becoming a
client now hold on look at my teeth
can i tell you something yes candid
i'm being candid with you yeah give
brian some goddamn braces
let's give them the clear aligners i'm
clearly looking at your teeth i'm
literally going with canada i tried the
other company didn't work
well it worked but i didn't stick with
it they didn't work it didn't work
i'm going with candid here's the thing
they work with licensed orthodontists
who are experts at tooth movement
uh they only work with orthodontists you
don't work with general dentists like
other companies
which is yes so you don't have to get
your teeth now i know some of your
bodies
may never hear from a doctor as you go
through treatment which is ridiculous
with cannon your treatment includes
remote monitoring by the same
orthodontist who created your plan
again i'm about to become a client of
this i've done my research
it sounds like a very good company you
never have to wonder how you're doing
you will always know
because you're working with the same
doctor average can of treatment is six
months
start seeing results way before then and
costs an average of 50 percent less
than invisalign which is what i did and
your bottom teeth look like a pug dog
they
still do get this right now man get
started today
from the comfort of your own home with
candids risk free starter kit and 75
off go to dot candidco.com fighter use
the code fighter that's candidco.com
fighter code fighter for your risk-free
starter kit and 75
off candyco.com and i will keep you guys
addressed as to how my teeth are
progressing under candid
not the best model but i will be uh
brandon
yes i want a whoop band i mean these two
dude they have new hot colors they have
cool looking ones
i want black all right done fine tell me
what i get with the fitness tracker
it gives you members access to their app
which provides personal insight and
recovery strain and sleep very important
when i did my whole
uh camp my my genome and stuff sure
doctor said do you track your sleep i
said no
i said but i'm going to with whoop
because it tracks your sleep better than
any other dude track your sleep that
workout you're going to attract that so
you know exactly how many calories
you're burning
how much strain you put out all right
and you know if
if you go hard today should you go hard
tomorrow it's going to show your
recovery
what you should do the loop strap is a
small little strap you can wear it
24 7 when you sleep in the shower when
you swim the
loop strap 3.0 has a five day battery
life on the go charging so you never
need to take it off it's waterproof like
i told you
the whoop strap 3.0 connects to
bluetooth low energy devices those
things to
heart rate uh compatible treadmills
bikes rowers your cell phone attracts
everything take the guesswork out you
were a
client before they became a supporters
yeah
yeah and i said hey this thick boy bike
club it's telling me i'm burning
40 000 calories how many am i really
burning i'm not true you burned 1200.
wow thick kid yep so it's great it's the
best
it's the best fitness place that you can
get the best the best mind your heart
rate 100 times per second
geez it's all through heart rate man for
you guys woop is offering 50
off with the code fighter at checkout go
to woop
that's w-h-o-o-p dot com enter the code
fighter and save 50
off all right sleep better recover
faster train smarter
optimize your performance with woo
all right we're in get off your phone
brandon
damn it burn them get
hope so we'll give it a shot
come on all right so um first of all
brendan wanted
to show you a clip brian and let me get
it up
oh of the documentary yes sir to hype
you up
where can he watch it at showtime
no i know that i know i'm in for enough
damage
can will it play on the on the computer
or the the
tv it's just a computer we had to do it
this way okay all right
well so give me one sec let me share my
screen check out this bird's eye view of
this [ __ ]
and hopefully the audio oh daddy get
here see you guys
yep a student
popular football player evil
child molester we find the defendant
guilty
i've never woken up in the morning and
wondered did we get the wrong guy
this trial was a sham there's been an
outcry
he was absolutely guilty they got it
wrong initially i was pretty convinced
of his innocence
now i wouldn't be surprised either way
wow now that that was so low quality
makes me not want to watch it
and i don't know what happened but i'm
all over it
if you don't watch it now after seeing
that i i understand i know but i'm all
over it that was
terrible but that was awful i don't know
if it's the feed or what but it chopped
and it sped up and then we lost
audio so it's chin's coven
probably i'll take a very fresh paste
i'll text it to you bro
thank you um all right so next one you
want to start with br
brand you're talking about the ferrari
crash do you want to go with that one
first
sure all right ferrari
do this guy f40 and crashed in the
[ __ ] tree
it's a two-point do i what's what's it
saying i didn't read oracle i saw the
headline chin
so it says it's on australia i think
it's 2.3 million ferrari f40
well that's does it say if he was
drinking or he just [ __ ]
he just spot it yeah there's not much uh
uh info on this guy
there's two people driving apparently
they're fine or two people in the car
the driver lost control and they're both
fine no injuries but the car
is just crazy 2.3 million what do you do
in this situation is this car
salvageable no no one's gonna no dude
it's over
it's over you do i mean [ __ ] man
2.3 million dollars yeah there's not
many of them so where the [ __ ] so where
are you gonna get the parts
send it to the goddamn factory oh god
and you have one of the greatest cars of
all time
2.3 million dollars how bad is the
damage that's
it's not good it's total look at that
that car is done it looks a little
wobbly but
2.3 million dollars fix it right now
those cars like the gt carreras
the porsches you know they're both
collectors they don't have abs braking
or
they don't have you know power lock rate
so it's like these guys probably used to
drive in the newer ferraris or whatever
they get in that thing and they're going
fast and there's no
you know it's problems man big problems
and that's a 2.3 million dollar car
it's an old dude it's like in this
all right well too bad leave it there
all right well uh brendan talks about
this show all the time
there's gigolos right dude
who watches gigolos this guy was the zen
master he was always like
like they'd be arguing like fellas let's
calm down what a surprise that's
no but he was my favorite one what a
surprise he really [ __ ] those girls
down well
he was kind he felt he he like they
would just you know what
you know what i would go on the limbs
say the other guys [ __ ] their clients
this guy made love dude but then you
know what somewhere he took a wrong turn
and he killed a lady uh chin let me see
this
phony [ __ ] sociopath for a second
bring up his regular picture first of
all look at his [ __ ] hair
oh wait you see his body bubba i
remember this guy dude
this guy was the guy was all like built
like a
yeah but but he was only dressed like a
goddamn you do yoga
and he's always zen and then ashley
killed a girl
that guy yeah he was like the nicest guy
i remember him very well and i was a fan
he was my favorite
he was like selling supplements that's a
good looking guy he had a good dick on
him
but he had a dick and he's a good
looking guy he made love to those
clients
while everyone else was [ __ ] he made
love look at his body
i know look at him yeah apparently he
got all on drugs and beat a woman to
death
wait let me see him there oh yeah oh
dude
god he has his nipples pierced he's a
man panther look at him
he's posing on a sailboat in a speedo
dude talk about aqua what are the
circumstances of him beating this woman
this poor woman to death
like it matters wait let me see him well
first of all i would like some details
chin let me see him in that let me see
him in that speedo his hair is fantastic
hold on
if this doesn't look like a serial
killer i don't know what doesn't
there he is well right there we should
all know
right there we should all go run for the
[ __ ] hills
dude look at his [ __ ] dick he's got a
great body oh my god the best body of
all time on the show he's
a silky conan we call him the silky
conan
um god he's bodied up do we have any
other
details yeah let me go to the article
again but i heard it was he was under
the influence of narcotics
and the girl they said they didn't
identify her yet but then i'm reading
other places that it could have been his
girlfriend
so he suddenly beat her up she ended up
dying and the cops got there and found
her
passed away jesus christ that's terrible
well is there any new article or just
the one i said didn't have much on it
huh no
i mean this is this is pretty much it
right here and what did he got
yeah 23 a.m they responded to a 911 call
from ramon after his girlfriend was
unresponsive
so this one says girlfriend the other
one say friends right here see
so they i mean he had a lot of friends
also known as clients okay
under the influence of narcotics beaten
to death
cocaine dude you know heart probably not
homeboy wait a minute look at his hair
probably meth hold up please
what's going on with his hair there well
he's just killed a person you're wearing
a wig
no god no well i don't ash doesn't wear
what's going on with that
something's going on with his [ __ ]
hairline bro yeah dude he's stressed out
because he just
beat a person to death well does he have
to wear his hair over to one side like
that
i don't think he can that's the weird
thing too his hair is just his hair is
just out of the place
he's a sociopath oh i'm sorry he didn't
get glammed up during his mug shot you
[ __ ]
he's so sure he just looks like he's out
of it yeah he's out of it man he just
beat another human being to death
exactly yeah he's a little out terrible
a little out of it absolutely terrible
well i wonder if he meant to kill her if
he just meant to beat her up
you know what i'm thinking so he didn't
mean to but what did you say i'm
thinking too like he has sex all the
time right so you know when people have
crazy sex sometimes they go a little too
crazy
excuse me i don't i don't absolutely
dodge him
what science is that i'm sorry about a
little too much sex they get a little
too crazy
you're talking about like yeah
dominatrix the girl asked you know to
get like slapped around and beaten up
and maybe he was on drugs and went too
far
no i don't know it's possible no no he
does sex for a living you don't
kill somebody no girl's like oh yeah
punch me in the [ __ ] yeah when you beat
someone to death it really is
it takes a lot and he's associated
a code word and he might have died
before yeah then there's a code word you
say like
oklahoma and then everything stops well
again
you know choking or slapping or spanking
is
is there's that you know what and then
there's beating someone to death
maybe their
that's two potheads coming up with a
safe well cokeheads
you keep saying coke dude no one [ __ ]
people up on coke
no man that's you're talking about meth
using the weird [ __ ]
master you're talking about some weird
[ __ ] man i don't know
you don't just tee off on a person i
don't wouldn't narcotics make you
murderous though i would just
math you're a murderer he dropped a lot
of acid
yeah but you're just a murderous person
it might have been something he's been
fantastic about since he was a kid
the [ __ ] people like this they have
this this sick twister you know what i
think
what i don't think we know what the [ __ ]
we're talking about
right because we don't know anything no
weren't there nope and then chin thinks
they were
uh have got had rough times and that's
the numbers
that's the worst this sex is not enough
i have to kill this guy
if you're a defense lawyer that's the
worst argument now my argument with the
safe word got mixed up
kind of works here yeah but you know
choking is a big thing with girls girls
love a lot of girls love choking so
sometimes you could choke him
unconscious possibly she doesn't wake up
i don't know
chin there's a difference between
choking and suffocating
then she got beaten to death so that's
not that doesn't sound like choking
yeah no all right uh moving on to what
happens although you attend
to your point there is an mma fighter
who was accused of choking his
girlfriend
oh no no no and then his dms lit the
[ __ ] up
by about by literally like hundreds of
girls saying hey you can choke me
anytime you want different though
domestic violence yeah yeah yeah but
that's just interesting to me that
that's like
what that happened i'm running shop i
don't support this conversation i don't
either i'm saying
that's a fact though that he got hit up
his dms kind of blew up
yeah i don't know so i'm just saying to
your point that there are people are
into
things people sexually and all over all
things but when you talk about somebody
who
beats somebody to death that's not bad
sorry yeah that's not sorry
like if she was choked on yeah even
beating somebody up like
if a woman has a heart is that
right you're like wait a minute that
means you're hitting them so many times
they die you're you're a murderer dude
yeah you know how hard is to beat
someone to death you know how hard you
gotta hit him
dude if i had to like someone's like how
many hits does it take to kill brian
cowan
how many how many hits does it take to
get to the center of town's brain
but i'm always moving dude 50
yeah to kill you 50 punches a long time
i'd have to get on top of you and you're
a big boy like a gorilla like this
yeah i would have to
literally i mean kick your head in dude
yeah you can kill me
oh you kill me pretty quickly though uh
you break my neck yeah but that ash guy
doesn't know jiu-jitsu no
he knows how to pump though yeah i've
seen him lay the
the wood dude really ah yeah you never
watched gigolos
i i watched a little i watched all six
seasons favorite show on showtime of all
time
and he puts it down oh he was fantastic
he really cared about the person too
that's why this is surprising
anybody else i would believe it him
unbelievable man killers tend to be
killers can put on a very
a very pretty cloak
size 15 shoe for example
kevin is the biggest she's a very nice
guy but we know that he's a warlock
and that he for reals if if he gave me a
lineup of
who off the jiggles would kill a person
he'd been dead last for me
and i love that show everybody i can't
believe it's off time you read about a
serial killer people like were so
shocked he was such a nice guy
but then i look at him um but then you
look at him it's like of course
jeffrey dahmer [ __ ] killed people
look at this psycho
yeah all right moving on
all right happy news
here we go okay
so there was a six-year-old boy who was
attacked by a german shepherd
because the dog was coming after his
little sister
he jumped in the way he ended up needing
to get 90 stitches
and while he was getting attacked by the
dog he somehow
managed to have enough strength to hold
onto his sister's hand and pull her back
into the house what a stud
he's a stun and it turns out that he
loves the avengers and so chris evans
tom holland um robert downey jr all gave
him a call
they're all giving him gifts inviting
him on to set yeah just love it
trying to take care of him wow what he
said today he said something like if
if i was gonna die it would better me
he said that when he saw the dog come
after his sister he knew what was going
to happen and he thought
if someone had to die he would rather
die than have his little sister how old
is he
six and she's four oh my god and it's so
cute you watch the videos he can't
get it in his uh he can't smile properly
right now because of all the stitches
but you can just tell how happy is he
gonna be okay he's gonna be fine
[ __ ] dude is it german shepherd it was a
german shepherd hopefully they killed
that [ __ ] dog
well if a dog does that to a kid you put
that dog down
i don't give a [ __ ] what anybody i'll do
it myself the dog does that to a child
that dog's not safe around kids i know
i'm killing your dog i'm gonna go get my
ak-15 i'm gonna tell you a story i mean
i had my dog i was very attached
to and i rescued my dog moto i loved him
he tried to bite a kid in the face i
took him right to the vet
and i said i gotta put this dog down the
vet talked me out of it
because he just the dog is so cute and
so nice
and he said please let me help you find
a home for this dog
and i did and i i found a home for him
with somebody but you were willing to
kill him
i was wanting to put him down because
i'm serious did he like
i [ __ ] love that did he get excited
like leave the kid's face oh
it happened twice where he tried to go
for a kid now
what he would do is that kids would put
their excited when kids put their face
near him he thought he got scared and he
would fight
i still can't have that i can't have it
you could have had him at another home
though well i i ended up putting him in
another home and i still have
reservations
you want to kill him i just i still feel
like
i still feel as though i don't know i i
felt
it was very tough decision and i was
talked into it by a vet
who explained to me you know because i
explained him what the what the
situation was
and the owners of the dog know that i
still felt a little bit like i should
have put the dog down i really do
but if you guys i love that [ __ ] dog
i love that
and i wouldn't look back because i don't
think a dog that that exhibits violence
toward
a child problem is that they can do too
much damage now he was a little dog
he would if he had been a big dog nobody
would have talked me out of it i don't
give a [ __ ] it wasn't but that
was it he was like a little quirky kind
of dog great dog
like a corgi mix and the only reason
i'm just being very honest the only
reason i i didn't put that dog down was
because
a dog with small a mouth like that's not
going to do the kind of damage if he had
been a german now
now some now did the vet go well sir
this dog's going to do no damn
no no no it's a corgi that don't do
damage yeah bite
a kid's face off yeah sure no they can
still bite like a [ __ ] but
it's a smaller also him am i right i
would have done it i know
and i would do it again yep let's find
that [ __ ] thing but if it was a
bigger dog
oh no no that would have talked me out
of it no i mean i put the dog down right
[ __ ] now yeah shoot him and i'm a dog
lover yeah kill him
it reminds me of that woman who was
attacked by a bunch of wiener dogs
oh yeah they killed her they killed her
remember that those weiner dogs
there's like 30 wiener dogs killing they
had a heart attack or something no they
killed her
yeah remember they killed her let me let
me tell you something
you you said well brian wants to kill
all those wiener dogs 30 wiener dogs on
me it's gonna be a long day for those
[ __ ] dogs
long days i know no i'm gonna kick i'm
gonna [ __ ] drop kick every one of
those [ __ ] dogs
yep here's my problem you keep saying
what you love dogs and now this is the
third time
i love dogs i'm a dog guy i keep saying
that i'm a dog guy are you threatening
to kill three dogs i don't have a time
for a dog that
exhibits aggression toward a child baby
a person an adult
i can work with yeah kids kids you're
not not in my neighborhood i'm pretty
sure that lady died by those court those
and we were laughing those weirdos
killed that poor lady
now i had a friend i think it was like
10 wiener dogs they were rabid
and they just they got a hold of her and
they just [ __ ]
i heard this with their little legs i
have to see that i have to see the
footage
now i also now i believe that as much as
i believe your friend hit by the car
there you go now i didn't i believe her
moore's one friend had a big pit bull
very big people and that dog had a
problem with anybody who had a hat on
and i'm talking about anybody old people
who wore a hat
that dog would try to get at that person
and i said to my friend i go
you see i believe that dog should be put
to sleep
or just leave him in the house dangerous
don't just leave him in the house well
he can't leave in the house but if he
gets out if you have a backyard attack
somebody with a hat on and kills them
that dog is so powerful you want to kill
him too now i got a problem with that
all right well you dude maybe you should
be a super avenger that just kills dogs
no
a huge pit bull that is that wants to
kill somebody wears a hat kill that's a
dangerous animal
kill
they said dashan's which are wiener dogs
right they're doctors yeah yeah they're
wiener dogs once again
once again you sick 30 [ __ ] wiener
dogs
killing everyone a long day for those
dogs you know what i'll say it free if
you have a problem with your dog
email kidshop.com because brian will
[ __ ] kill your dog
now those dogs can jump and bite your
balls so that's a problem you might have
some problems
guess what guess the movie if
the dogs come near me i will dropkick
the dogs i will dropkick the dogs
what's the movie and who's the actor
kevin
the actress tom cruise what's the movie
oh
jerry mcgregor no
oh um uh is it one where he's a
bartender do you hear me i will
drop kick is it dogs oh mission
impossible magnolia
never saw that he's going to see his
dying dad no i never saw it
[ __ ] tom cruise is incredible in that
movie and he's kind of this guy has died
his kid
is dying and he's got all these dogs
because if the dogs come near me i will
drop kick
what else you got tin all right next one
here we go okay last wednesday there was
a huge twitter hack
where 130 users accounts were
hacked into and people like elon musk
kanye west
apple and a couple other verified
accounts ended up pushing some sort of
like bitcoin scam
they quickly uh found out what was
happening and that somebody hacked
into multiple accounts and they actually
suspended verified accounts from
tweeting anything for about
two hours was it christy tegan too or
no that's a different thing no i think
that was completely different
yeah that was different that was like a
jeffrey epstein thing yeah
yeah that's super dark uh this is weird
because it's alarming because they
actually tricked
twitter employees that's how they got a
hold of everything and information
they said 60 something in bitcoin
something crazy no they're only a
hundred thousand dollars but the problem
is they got everyone's personal
information
twitter is saying that there were only i
believe it was eight accounts
who had their information stolen and
none of them were verified
accounts but we don't know that for sure
that's just their statement they're not
covering their ass
it's rough
what else you got all right next one
so a man and his family were staying in
a friend's home
over the weekend and at one in the
morning the father came downstairs
because he heard a commotion in the
kitchen and he thought it was gonna be a
bear
and he was hoping that when he went
downstairs it wasn't going to be a bear
but he had to check up on his kids
who were staying in the downstairs
bedroom so when he went into the kitchen
he saw the bear
they both looked at each other in the
eyes he freaked out but tried to shoo
the bear away into the garage
he got the bear out almost out the door
when the sound of the garage door
opening freaked him out and that's when
the bear attacked him
that makes the beard turn around like
what the [ __ ]
yeah the bear ended up running away he
called the police
the police thankfully the man is okay he
just has
oh these terrible got some bear scars it
just kind of
compares them out of the way they found
a 400 pound bear that they
think was the black bear in the kitchen
and they killed it
they killed him for what well you can't
get you can't break into people's
kitchens
but you have food in there dude i had
pie yeah i had pie
but he didn't kill anyone they just put
them down got to bear proof your kitchen
dude that's such [ __ ] it's a bummer
400 pound bear that's a huge but he just
came in the kitchen was like all right
there's nothing i'm going to leave now
like kill
him 400 pounds but you're also in his
you're in his
world dude you're in the forest
god i want to bring you to a dog park
man dog glitch love dogs
put that [ __ ] thing down love dogs i
just don't sound like
you want to kill him got this [ __ ]
bit you just killed the bear
you didn't even kill a guy i would drop
kick that [ __ ] bear
you definitely kill him bear's a big dog
i don't know i don't think i'd kill that
bear i feel bad about the bear let the
bear live
the bear was just got he got scared i
thought you only killed the animals if
they taste human blood that thing was
like yeah
[ __ ] freaked out slap the [ __ ] out of
that guy you wouldn't ran off you don't
know
bear might have bitten him good dog dude
he'd be way worse enough the bear bit
his face
no the bear was like everybody see the
claws like this
yeah or it's a bite mark no it looks
like it's got to be dead
those are claw you've seen you know it
does look like a claw he seems fine
it's a big clump kind of cool though now
you have a bear mark
yeah i mean the bear's [ __ ] dead way
to go dude
also call the cops cops like 400 pounds
but also the cops like
all right i guess we're on our way but
they might have is the thing still there
no all right what do you want us to read
a police report what do you want well
you might want to kill a bear
because he's used to breaking into
kitchens he broke into one kitchen
he's not a serial burglar dude that's
not a capital crime
he got one that's impossible do you
think how long that bears been on this
planet to be 400 pounds i agree he's
probably how old
25 at least he breaks into one house
[ __ ] kill one kill them
for being a pie eater dude they're
taking capital offense they're probably
cooking who knows
chilly if your dog bites kids pull the
[ __ ] dog down
but if a bear comes in and he wants some
pie one house garage door it's one house
one house let the bear live
he's 400 pounds one house at 25 years on
the show no fat for the winter
you kill him trying to fatten up for the
winter and you kill him because he's
trying to get a little [ __ ] weight on
his body
i could use some weight on my body covid
made me skinny [ __ ] i wish i had more
bear in me
you can't eat beer either unless you
really think it well what else you got
i like your bandanas thanks man here's
the next one
okay so kanye west held a presidential
campaign speech in south carolina
where he had a full-on meltdown
because he said that harriet tubman
didn't free the slaves that she actually
just
gave them away to other oppressive white
people
interesting and he also talked about um
the females choice to decide whether to
abort a child or not by saying that
he didn't want kim to keep his daughter
and he started crying
saying i was going to kill my daughter
and this is the clip
so he's off the off medication
dude he is not doing well
[Music]
you know what i don't believe that i
don't like seeing that well you know
what he's having a meltdown he's off
medication b
i don't believe one word of it okay as
soon as you got pregnant i guarantee it
wasn't like oh we gotta you have an
abortion kim kardashian's like what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
hey that never happened b he's off
medication is he wearing a bulletproof
vest
he was wearing a bulletproof security
vest
he's not he's he probably shouldn't be
run for president do you think
that was the first press conference yeah
that didn't go well
that did not go well sometimes i think
america he realized he couldn't
i think he did get on a ballot somewhere
but he realized that he was too
late he couldn't get on the bout in
florida i think it was like ah [ __ ]
dude that's that's very scary it's very
scary it's very alarming
he's crying and freaking out well he's
just he's mentally ill brandon
yeah go kill dogs with them
god damn man that's sad i don't like
seeing that i don't like seeing and
somebody melt down like that
i know i hate when i see billionaires
freaking out man no that's that's no
joke
but also but it's that's kanye west all
right i i didn't realize
people have way bigger problems man i
don't think i realized he really had
mental illness
are you kidding me yeah dude you never
seen him pop off before no
he did he got put into insane asylum
makes cool shoes really tallonious monk
who was one of the greatest
jazz pianists he started
like he was a genius and his he's
and you can see it on there's actually a
video of it he would start
kind of walk in a circle just started
like a ballerina just would kind of
start twirling and talking
to himself and he slowly just went crazy
he didn't talk to him well he didn't
really talk to himself he just
that's that's a what is that a manic
episode or something
he's freaking out man i also think he
realizes he's in over his head trying to
run for president united states i was
like
ah because people ask him real questions
like gun laws and pandemics and
[ __ ] inflation and stocks and the
market and he's like
uh what the [ __ ] a little bit more
interesting i was going to kill my
daughter though
the [ __ ] he just you know oh yeah
it's funny i know somebody who's crazy
who ran for president
and then i i was like and then my friend
said did you see what happened we were
eating
and she never took her gum out of her
mouth and she had a whole meal i swear
to god see i call that talent
i know i did too and she needed a salad
and my friend said did you notice that
she never took her gum out whoa
and then she ended up being crazy well
crazy is a
i don't know what that word means but
mental she had men crazy cool
oh yeah connie's not doing well i i have
i'll tell you
but you but you also gotta you have to
think about the kardashians too it has
to be a little
i mean they're around him all the time
so
you know see what what the [ __ ] going
on what's the what's the
family dynamic like you know it's so
strange man
i'll tell you a story off here i don't
know if i can tell it on there
okay about mental illness about my
experience with somebody who
i dated who had and it ended badly for
her
you know anyway guess i want to hear
that story
yeah i'll tell you later she died i
don't want to be just did she follow her
memory did she die yeah
oh definitely don't want to hear it yeah
tell us about killing dogs
no i just think mental illness is so
serious and and we don't know anything
about it we don't [ __ ] know anything
about it man
and so when you a guy like that like who
has everything
and has a manic episode like that i
really hate seeing that [ __ ] [ __ ] but he
also
thinks when he takes medication it
limits him creatively so he stopped
his medication you know so there's that
that makes sense maybe
you know that's what they say i don't
know but you think kim kardashian the
rest of family is like dude what the
[ __ ]
yeah hang out this guy all the time you
realize having to live with that it's
like
it's like when you hear so i have one
experience with alcohol like real
alcoholism where
you see somebody when they get drunk and
some people they're really nice and they
start drinking and they get
nasty more than nasty they become
terrifying yeah
i saw that once and uh it was it was the
father of somebody i knew
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah i mean i saw
my friend i went oh that's why you don't
talk to this person yeah
he goes oh no you have no idea i went oh
now i have an idea i had no idea
so woof i don't know man
i don't know i'm woefully ignorant about
this i'll tell you who i'm worried about
i don't know if it's not convinced it's
nick cannon man he's been posting some
dark [ __ ] i'm a nick cannon fan one of
his best friends
committed suicide i don't know i know
just recently
and then nick cam has been posting dark
stuff so he's having a meltdown nick
is yeah but you know fox stood by him
fox said they're still in the host mass
singer he apologized
maybe you just haven't again i'm a you
and i both and i think
most of us realize that you can have
moments in your life
where you're not yourself when you
something happens
and you go crazy no you should be
allowed to know
you can't it's bad it's bad it's bad is
it possible though that he's
no not himself and crazy no
no you can't be you can't be anti-jew
anti-semitic
and you know that and say white people
are the devil and lesser and we're you
know he's just
you know we've said some [ __ ] on here
but i've never said anything
ever even remotely to those well because
i don't feel that way
like in other words i i i don't say i've
never seen i don't know how many hours
of pocket even when we're together i
don't say things that are off cold
never but how many i don't feel that way
but
yeah but that's not you know him saying
that's not
those were well thought out thoughts
that he had this wasn't him
he was having a conversation with
another man right and they're going back
and forth
well you know it's like this like when
you see somebody who gets drunk and they
become an [ __ ]
it's like that's not the alcohol you're
actually an [ __ ]
yeah but then you know then i'm saying
they can't like double down on it a
little bit you know
and then like you know the black
community supported him
because he wouldn't apologize and then
he apologized
to the jews so what he said was wrong so
you have both
sides mad at you so you get it from both
angles
it's just uh you know it's just tragic
man sucks
so what's going to happen to him he's
still fox is still standing by him well
he has his you know he's
a nate cain's a big deal man you know he
he was made to mariah carey as their
you know the mariah carey money he had
you know he owns weiland out which was a
huge success was on here for 15 years
he you know he's a host of mass singer i
think he's a producer for that show too
that he you know has his daily radio
show he has a syndicated
talk show that's they're going to delay
it now but oh well he's
next ballin man always has been that's
why he gets so much hate
so i don't know hopefully he's okay he's
like he's just working he's been posting
some dark stuff
yeah yeah yeah exactly it's like the
system has
made him a rich man yeah all right
he's not his mental health was you know
he like did some post then tagged
himself in heaven
like dark [ __ ] man you hope he's all
right
next current event please alrighty
this is kind of neat so uh younger kids
are taking advantage of the whole mask
thing so they're
dressing up as old people to buy alcohol
smart
some of them are pretty good they're
getting away with it huh
yep and this is i think a dude put a wig
on
a wig you know those things you put on
top of a scarf on top it makes you look
like you're an older woman too
so that's a fun one i'm sure and uh
let's go over here
yeah the lego store's like we're just
trying to get hey guys he gives a [ __ ]
what happened check this out
a documentary filmmaker who's doing a
documentary about sharks
was attacked by a shark when she was on
a day off you know
you know what i don't like is this
showing that thick ass great white shark
because it's not what it is i would bet
money she didn't get attacked by that
you know what dude
[ __ ] a right every time they tell me
about a shark attack
they they post that [ __ ] picture i'm
like great white
and then it was a lemon shark and you
got bit on the ankle it was a nurse
shark
it's a nurse shark what find out what
kind of shark attack does it say
i don't think i saw the name of the
shark yeah what a surprise
and how bad was the attack well i'll
show you she got her
uh airlifted and she was actually still
about the sharks after she got
bitten i'll play this little she's
smiling there she is in remarkably good
speech
get the [ __ ] out she's a little snippet
of what she said to the media when she
was wheeled into hospital
sharks rule you love shots
oh no where'd you get bit she didn't see
eye to eye with a [ __ ] great wife by
the
way
she's australian so that was in
australia could have been a bull shark
could have been a tiger could have been
a [ __ ] great white
i'm going with gray white but also it
could also been a lemon shark
could have been but i want to know what
happened to her did they need an air
lifter
can we get any more [ __ ] research you
got nothing else
her hold on so no they don't they don't
even tell me her name i tried different
websites they don't say her name she's a
documentary filmmaker but it says right
how to brush her [ __ ] leg on some
coral
she's she's in stable condition her
injuries are significant including deep
lacerations to her lower left leg and
possible ankle fracture
the theme that's really bitter hard
again
probably great white probably great
right but you might have been that fat
great white
broke her ankle and look well
that's a big mouth i'm going with the lt
gray great great whites will bite and
let go
they bite let go and then they come back
let you bleed out now
i i'm pretty sure she's bit by a seer
shark there some sharks
like that woman in queensland swimming
back from the raft her husband said
she just disappeared the whole body
never found her yeah a giant shark went
i'm gonna swallow you whole
yeah it's a great white well i take it
back that lady was not bit by lemon
structure the worst is actually
women like 20 year old his mom's
watching him
and he got bit in half hey hey look at
me
that video is fake no it's not it's not
a video
it's a story they told you that story
hi mom your mom told you that yeah all
right
carry on chin yeah
i'm sure you guys have seen this video
by now it's this bear
oh this is somewhere in mexico it's at a
wildlife park i think in mexico
yeah and she the girl that the bear is
sort of touching the girl is actually
taking a selfie
while it's happening i'll play it for
you can people man
they kill this beer too saw this no bear
just kept
oh wait they were just chilling they're
like holy [ __ ]
oh that bear's trying to [ __ ] bears
coming back your neck
oh he's probably checking for food in
that backpack
does the bear attack her nah oh that's
it
that was it but the the reason why this
video is interesting is because the girl
when this is happening
she puts her she pulls out her camera
instead of like freaking out doing it
for the gram
well they do you look they do look
cuddly there oh [ __ ]
going for a single leg they look cuddly
don't they
and then she slowly walks back and the
bear leaves
and i'll show you the i think there's
another angle this is from rex chapman
no no no hey
what's up it's your phone she lifts her
phone up to do a selfie
probably pretty good selfie
crazy though jesus christ
yeah you don't want to [ __ ] around well
there's some people that take selfies
then fall off the top of the mountain
die
[ __ ] just not a good way to go man
or they get eaten by a bear so it all
depends yeah
well fellas that was it all right well
we're back in studio we just need you
back in here chin the whole gang's back
i know you've gotten swabs are you
taking the test
uh so i'm gonna probably wait until
tomorrow to take the test and
they could take one again like thursday
yep or friday
yeah i don't think yep uh okey-dokey
so we'll see you maybe next week chad i
hope so
yeah [ __ ] well everybody
all right guys we're back in studio baby
see you wednesday see you this the final
kid route